à partir de mardi ses pailles en
plastique seront interdites dans les
restaurants et les commerces
alimentaires de Montréal mais ce n'est
pas tout les assiettes les tasses les
Verts les couvercles les bâtonnets les
ustensiles ainsi que les barquettes tous
des articles en plastique à usage unique
seront aussi bannis ça va permettre de
manger dans de la vraie vaisselle ce qui
est beaucoup plus agréable puis pour le
reste je passe une bonne idée aussi il
faut juste trouver les bonnes techniques
pour le théâtre c'est sûr que
ça on a emporté
mais seulement sur le client en fait la
demande une transition écologique qui
selon la ville devenait inévitable pour
atteindre sa cible zéro déchet d'ici
2030 c'est un gros défi on vous dit ce
règlement là va toucher 8400 commerces
de Montréal c'est anormal qu'aujourd'hui
on peut savoir un objet seulement
quelques secondes dans nos mains et le
jeter c'est un gaspillage et hanté si
plusieurs commerçants avaient déjà
entamé leur transition au vu de la
réglementation annoncée en août 2021
c'est quand même assez facile à trouver
les substituts ou des des on va pas par
exemple on va remplacer les pailles en
plastique on voulait remplacera des
pailles en agave ce qui coince c'est
l'écoulement de l'inventaire des gens en
stock comme pour ce restaurant de l'île
des sœurs mais là on va faire quoi on va
les jeter au lieu des utiliser c'est un
peu
c'est un peu de sens un problème dont la
ville d'y être consciente la main ne
viendra pas à la première visite des
inspecteurs mais pour lequel les
contrevenants s'exposent à des amendes
pouvant aller jusqu'à 4000 dollars et
combien sont plus dispendieux pour les
commerçants donc automatiquement nous on
a un frais supplémentaire ils ont fait
le travail de communication mais on
croit tout de même qu'il faut quand même
laisser une certaine période
d'adaptation avant d'envoyer les
inspecteurs le règlement ne s'applique
pas au commerce qui offre uniquement la
livraison à domicile et aux organismes
d'aide alimentaire ici Daniel Kadjo
Radio-Canada Montréal